I had a very weird you know one of the
high water weirdness events of my life
was when I was young I used to I was I
wanted the dmt flesh to last longer
so I used to smoke it at the height of
LSD trips and one Christmas vacation
this rooming house that I managed in
Berkeley had been everybody had gone
home for Christmas I thought and so I
decided I would take some Ella he is
loved auntie and and so I took the other
D and then I smoked the DMT it was just
nuts I mean it's nuts enough but this
was like turbocharged and that went on
and on and on and finally I there was a
woman who I rented a room to upstairs
named rosemary who was supposed to be in
Minnesota and she was a actress and very
projective and did everything with great
flair and she apparently came back early
from Christmas vacation so she hit the
front steps running of this house and
used her key to let herself into the
front door and came right around to my
door and started beating on my door well
I am by nature a very paranoid person I
mean
I can be the Rio young with Yasu in the
middle of the Amazon basin and if I'm
out in the rain for a smoking and joint
and a stick is broken anywhere near me I
immediately hide you know I'm very
paranoid this woman left herself in and
comes with clenched fists on my bedroom
door well I like underwent and I was in
the elf space and they were screeching
and chattering and showing me all this
stuff and then she did this I like I
flew I jumped like I peed in the air and
landed on my feet and it was it was as
though and don't try this at home it was
as though the sudden flash of adrenaline
and the sudden movement that I made
broke up the ordinary division between
the trip and normal normality or
something anyway I pulled the trip with
me into the room I was now standing in
the room eyes open but the elf creatures
had come with me and everything had just
been like reacted up to some immense
level of intensity and there were these
rotating geometric things in the room
hanging in the air and it was like
moving in this jerky motion this thing
was going click
and every time it would make this large
metallic click these plastic
triangle-shaped brightly colored chips
there's something like little pieces of
a4 tile or something would fly across
the room and each one of them had a
letter on it in an alien language sort
of like Ebru or Sanskrit and it's just
there was several of these machines and
these things were ricocheting off the
wall and I had an elf hanging off each
hand
so I stagger over to the door fling it
back and look at her and say something
like wait yeah and she realized at that
point what my problem was
and retreated but I've never forgotten
it's the one time that is that they went
literary on me and not only did I see
them not only did I hear them but I they
were printing on the air the message as
well
very curious